- Whoa, thirsty.
Hey, I'm Terry Crews,
and I'm about to read some thirst tweets.
Let's get this on.
(upbeat music)
Thirsty tweets.
Terry Crews, you are
one sexy mother (bleep).
Hashtag big, hashtag chocolate man.
(laughs)
Now that's true.
I'm chocolate.
With little almond, so I'm nuts too.
So it's okay.
(laughs)
I wanna lather up Terry
Crews, lay him down,
and slide my body all over his ripples.
What in the world?
You know what?
I wanna do that to myself, too.
Terry Crews is so sexy,
too bad he's married.
(laughs)
You know what's funny?
You know what, the fact that I am married
is the only thing that makes you sexy.
'Cause I remember, when I was single,
wasn't nobody feeling for me!
Nobody!
Does anyone else think Terry Crews
would be great in bed?
(laughs)
You know, boy, y'all in
love with that fantasy.
I'm trying to tell you.
Ask my wife, she's over it.
Terry Crews can take his
shirt off any time he wants,
that is fine with me.
You know what, I do!
I do!
I take my shirt off, literally,
if it's a little bit too hot, it's gone,
so it's no problem.
You know what,
me taking my shirt off
is family entertainment.
Christmas list.
Beanbag chair, sex appeal,
sexy Terry Crews calendar.
(laughs)
That's really cute.
There's nothing to say about that.
Thank you, I really like that.
Terry Crews meaty head equals Drake.
(laughs)
You know what, this head is meaty.
I'm trying to say, you look at it.
Look at that sucker.
Look how it, look at how
it just kinda (groans).
You can just put a finger
in between each wave.
Now look, one ear at a time.
I'm on, boy.
Wouldn't you like that.
(laughs)
Hey, Terry Crews, this
might be a bit forward,
but may I please lick
your biceps like a mom
cleaning up a melting ice
cream cone for her kid.
(laughs)
First of all, this is probably
the best piece of fiction
I have ever read.
There's drama here, there's a whole story,
there's people involved.
This is a movie.
I'm gonna turn this
tweet into a film idea.
Terry Crews got that
let me lick whip cream
off your body type body.
Well you just copying
the dude from before.
This is plagiarism.
Plagiarism.
We're already got the movie
with the licking biceps.
Come on.
Can we be a little more
inventive with your thirst.
Terry Crews and all these muscles!
I bet he is the tea in bed.
Again, it's the fantasy, y'all.
It ain't the tea.
It's not the tea.
I just had, I'm breaking the myth.
I'm a myth buster right now.
Me and the boys talking about Terry Crews,
and my buddy Jaden goes,
"I'd let him kiss me on the
cheek and hold his pocket."
(laughs)
Oh, man, you and the guys,
you know what I mean.
Hanging out, I guess, you know what.
I still want to rub my ass on Terry Crews.
You know what, he said that
like he been saying this so long.
Like he been saying this for years.
And look, you still wanna do that?
Yeah.
Yeah, I still wanna rub
my ass on Terry Crews.
Who would you tweet that?
Hey, this is Terry
Crews and I have enjoyed
reading these thirsty tweets.
Thank you for your thirst.
I appreciate it.
I hope you're not thirsty anymore.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)